le deuxième Maze Runner laisse tomber le
procès des scores de boom commence J'adore travailler avec
Wes parce qu'il est vraiment excité quand
il explique des choses, il va
simplement jouer toute la scène, pas
même juste votre partie que tout ce que
je pense qu'il est un  génie, je pense sincèrement
que son esprit fonctionne à un
niveau différent de nous tous, puis il explique
tout avec beaucoup de détails qui
me disent qu'il est ravi de faire cela, il veut
le meilleur de nous et donc je veux lui donner
mon  mieux, il propose des dessins
et des animations et des trucs sur ce à quoi les
choses vont ressembler quand nous les
regardons, c'est bien d'avoir des gens qui
vous tiennent à cœur autour de vous, vous savez, alors
nous allons continuer cette tradition et
espérons que cela se voit  sur le film essentiellement, je
pense que c'est le cas, il s'amuse à mixer le film,
il y a énormément de stress pour voter
et il ne le montre tout simplement pas vraiment, nous
allons faire exploser des bâtiments avec
beaucoup de personnages vraiment cool cette
fois, donc ça devrait être vraiment  coloré et
amusant, nous verrons qui vous survivra essentiellement